[Music]
and the rapid development of
vaccinations has been critical in
helping
millions of americans return to a
post-pandemic world
and now all eyes are on the development
of vaccination passports
a vaccine passport is essentially the
same technology that you use when you
get on an airplane and you download your
boarding passes
it is just a qr code technology there
are over 13 different solutions or
apps out there so this is the technology
problem that the brightest minds from
ibm to microsoft
and even healthcare providers like mayo
clinic are coming together on
we don't have a national database of
who's gotten vaccinated and who hasn't
so
technology is going to have to come in
and fill the gaps of us providing
that proof now the concept of
vaccination documentation is nothing new
says business and tech expert shibani
joshi
some countries like iceland already
require proof of certain vaccinations
for entry
and as of right now if you are planning
to go on any major cruise lines you are
going to have to be fully vaccinated and
prove your status before you can step on
board
and while vaccine passports are still in
development as she said
the goal is that they will be safe
private and limited to confirmation
not your entire medical record it will
also be easily
shareable with your health care
providers when needed